what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here today saw a request
for this decided to kill some time our
internet spectrum you guys suck spectrum
can't tell you how awful spectrum
internet is specifically in my the
hawkeye reaction
been uploading for for a very very long
time had to call them i think the 15th
visit this year they're sending someone
here for the same there's a signal
problem we gotta fix it so at 5 30 in
the morning we're like let's shoot this
pitch meeting reaction then
slap happiest let's
do it guys you know it's gonna be good
it's gonna be a great stress relief the
joy of ryan george
[Music]
so you have a spider-man sequel for me
yes sir i do the third entry in the i
guess home trilogy it seems like we
decided that was a thing at a certain
point so what happens in this movie
peter is super famous because mysterio
revealed his identity in the last movie
right oh yeah yeah so his world's turned
upside down the media is all over him
and his friends that flash guy writes a
whole book about it oh boy and there are
also some legal troubles involved so
they get this they get matt murdock in
charlie cox he's from the netflix show
yeah he is oh boy it doesn't get much
crazier than that
oh you have no idea
i have idea no cause sir check this out
i was thinking we get andrew garfield to
come in as spider-man from another
universe oh
yeah i mean he's great okay i was
expecting a bigger reaction than that
but also we get toby mcguire in as
spider-man 2. good actor sure
sir toby maguire i did love seabiscuit
that was great seabiscuit is tight they
both played spider-man before oh did
they yeah in other movies they oh i
don't i guess i missed those
really i mean i have no recollection but
the movie will still work right
i guess okay great so let's hear it hey
okay uh
i mean i was hoping we could get alfred
molina to come in as doc ock oh he was
fantastic in chocolate okay
oh really yeah the imp none of this is
gonna land the way i wanted to if you
haven't watched those five movies five
movies okay
all right please it's you gotta do it
you gotta do it okay yeah that is so
funny like he just totally subverted the
expectation of what you think you would
do for a pitch meeting in that moment we
kind of touched on our spoiler review
how if they didn't show any of that of
villains especially because sony's plan
originally like the head of sony was
doing an interview with los angeles
times and they were right next to us
when we were at the premiere they're
saying like originally we didn't want to
show any of the villains or even let the
public know
but uh you know things started getting
leaked so we decided to start showing
them when i heard that i was like but i
feel like that should have always been
the plan a little bit right because
what if the fan base hadn't seen those
yeah
what if you had a large version of the
odds like where are they from let's clue
you in that you need to do your homework
if you haven't already i mean even for
people who have seen them a lot of them
felt like it was necessary for them to
re-watch them in order to go into that
so yeah i just thought that was like uh
this is that's a little poignant in my
opinion
[Music]
so what did you think yeah you know i
mean some of that was great what was
that a jazz thing about that oh we don't
need to talk about that okay now listen
to this i'm thinking we get willem dafoe
back as green goblin he's from the first
movie oh there's the reaction i'm going
for i was also thinking we'd get thomas
hayden church back as sandman and rhys
back as lizards he's from the third
movie and he's from the first movie of
the rebooted movie that's right and also
jamie foxx is electro he's from the
second movie of the rebooted movies he
sure is sir they're all from the other
movies amazing hey what about james
franco should we get him back
dane dehaan well okay then so what
happened no harry okay so it turns out
that being the most famous person in the
world has kind of ruined peter and mj
and ned's chances of getting into mit oh
okay and so peter feels bad so he goes
to see dr strange to ask him to cast a
spell to make everybody forget he's
spider-man and how does that go oh not
well cersei he starts the spell but then
peter keeps asking for little changes to
it like he wants mj to remember him so
doctor strange takes a minute to just
talk it through no no no no no god no
so the movie can happen oh okay gotcha
did electro know that peter parker was
spider-man no he didn't so okay so
eventually peter's gonna capture look
over there
very fun and then dr strange makes this
box that'll send everybody back to their
universes oh great but the thing is they
all got zapped over here pretty much
right before they died so peter's like
well we have to help them we can't just
send them to die oh but dr strange says
no so peter steals the box and then dr
strange brings him into the mirror
dimension which he controls oh man it's
gonna be tough for peter to beat strange
in there actually it's going to be super
easy barely an inconvenience oh really
yeah you could see the math on yourself
yeah
that works kinda i love that because
every time i've seen it i'm like i don't
exactly know what math he's doing i know
he's saying geometry i guess i kind of
get it i don't really know geometry that
well it's math salad yeah i'm going hey
these are mathematical these are
geometric shapes let's just have him say
math and then fix the problem really
quick with another geometric shape
because a lot of it is he's like
spitballing so fast with a close-up on
him and then close-ups on where the webs
are landing yeah and then oh okay he he
did something and it looks cool yeah
all right
i roll with it every time
because for all i know
they probably did it mathematically
accurate and i'd compute them to know if
they did it
or not the computers that built and
simulated that effect sequence did a lot
of math to make that happen
what else is going to happen well
there's kind of this consensus on the
internet that everybody's tired of
seeing uncle ben die in spider-man
projects that does seem to happen a lot
yeah so i figured we don't hear that
right and instead we kill aunt may oh my
god green goblin's gonna blow her up and
right before she dies she's gonna tell
peter you know with great power must
also come great responsibility yeah that
lesson just doesn't carry the same
weight without one of your parents
siblings violently dying very true sir
so anyway then ned is gonna use doctor
strange's sling ring to try and open a
portal to get peter and that's a thing
he can do yeah we're gonna throw in a
line about him having magic in his
family so he can do portals now wow okay
so we're just kind of crapping on doctor
strange's abilities in this country a
little bit a little yeah well okay then
[Laughter]
it did take dr strange a while to figure
that out
yeah doctor strange does kind of get
nerfed a little bit in this movie if you
thought dr strange's origin story was a
little bit rushing how he got so good at
his abilities so quick wait till you see
ned
magic just runs easily for all these
people once you know you have it you can
do it pretty much instantly so then
these portals open and that's how these
other peter parkers come in the ones
played by toby mcguire and andrew
garfield oh wow wow wow wow it's gonna
be very nostalgic sir so i guess they
each get like a cameo line like a little
jokey thing oh no they're like in the
movie now oh they are yeah full-on
characters with effects on the plot and
everything okay well that's not usually
how these things go yeah no we'll see
this movie's kind of a love letter to
the spider-man movies and their fans oh
that's nice i like that yeah a massively
lucrative showcase of our intellectual
property yeah okay the first thing you
said sounded a lot more romantic though
cashing in on nostalgia but done right
you had it the first time oh okay gotcha
so does ned keep making portals no he
stops at two i mean why not keep trying
they could get tom holland they could
see how many spider-mans they can get
the scene has served its purpose sir we
gotta move on
so anyway then eventually all the spider
guys are gonna get together and do some
science to make cures for the bad guys
very cool and then there's gonna be this
big fight where they try to cure them
all amazing man it's going to be a
little hard to keep track of which
spider-man's witch during the big fight
huh actually yeah a little all right and
so eventually tom holland is so mad that
he's about to kill green goblin oh boy
but toby mcguire steps in and stops him
using nothing but his wise face and then
he gets stabbed oh no is he okay oh
yeah oh yeah he's all right all right
it was kind of rude of you emotionally
you know so none of those spidey senses
went off when he was about to get
stabbed no because they were having a
moment spidey senses don't work if
you're having a moment oh good to know
yeah you know regarding that toby moment
as much of a shocker as it is the first
time because it really does play on your
feelings of oh no are they gonna kill
off toby maguire like i remember being
like upset at the movie the first time i
watched it thinking they were actually
gonna do that
um but yeah every time i rewatch it i do
have that thought of how come he didn't
sense it okay and i do think there is a
little bit of a weird beat just in kind
of terms of the editing when he is
just like yeah i've been sad before like
oh i guess there was no
there's no snakes at all there's nothing
to worry about at that moment yeah he's
not concerned nobody's concerned they
were concerned wrongfully they didn't
have to check on him or something like
that you know
before it's fine yeah so then it looks
like all these other people are about to
come in from other dimensions it's about
to be nuts oh no so tom holland peter
has dr strange cast a new spell where
everybody forgets about peter parker
entirely oh very selfless it is so then
all the villains get sent back to their
universes all cured and whatnot are they
being sent back to just a second before
they're killed yeah maybe so anyway then
it's all very sad for tom hall and
spider-man because mj and ned don't
remember him oh that's sad yeah and he's
about to go explain the whole situation
to them but then he realizes they're
probably better off without him in their
lives very sad it is yeah so he's got to
get an apartment all by himself and
start over so he still has like a social
security number like the government
still remembers him
maybe what happens with all the videos
and news reports about him being
spider-man i guess the memory spell
works on computer memory also what about
flash's book that he wrote okay look sir
i'm gonna need you to get all the way
off my back about this memory spell okay
we're going for a clean slate kind of
thing here oh okay let me get off of
that thing thanks so what do you think
oh it sounds like a really good time you
know i'm just how are we gonna market
this without spoiling all this crazy
stuff uh
leaks
yeah that'll work let's do that
oh god
awesome yeah you guys gotta subscribe to
ryan george's personal youtube channel
as well as screen read mainly for the
pitch meetings that's the main reason of
subscribing [ __ ] is screw grant
tuesdays yeah man the leaks were the
best marketing ever the best marketing
ever now it's time to figure out how
many of them were intentional oh man i
wonder if john campbell wasn't on
anything well that was fun that was fun
but i gotta say you know i feel like
ryan george kind of held back a little
bit on this one i do gotta say i feel
like yeah there's something especially
with the producer
character it was really funny at first
but then he seemed like he really didn't
seem to care as much and there's a lot
of things about the villains that we've
heard a lot of people sort of criticize
that i thought he would kind of go into
i guess that's the thing yeah i feel
like this
going in i expected this to be like a
litany of all the you know plot holes
and and weird details that are there
that we all lovingly look past for the
qualities that the movie obviously has
but yeah it feels like a lot of those
were kind of left like i really
appreciated the whole subversion at the
beginning with the producer but yeah it
does feel like there are a lot of stones
maybe left unturned yeah like i thought
he might talk about like lizard being a
little more one-dimensional
or like sam and all and sand the whole
time and the shot at them at the end or
electro like because he normally takes
like the common criticisms you're
hearing and then really amplifies them
and makes them even more yeah it makes
more outstanding or maybe he thought
that'd be too expected and decided to
subvert our expectations by not calling
them out or
he flat i didn't have a problem
yeah maybe maybe you just thought it was
a lot more uh smooth and streamlined
than some other people yeah
or maybe he's a really busy guy yeah
he just didn't have time to do a
20-minute [ __ ]
all right guys either way that was still
really fun a lot of these jokes really
made us crack up guys check him out hey
hopefully hawkeye's uploaded
now